in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, per September 5th, on which we commemorate
the Holy Hyromarter Athanasius, abbot of the monastery of Saint Simeon the
Stylite at Brest-Litovsk.
Saint Athanasius was born in the province of Minsk in the year 1596.
The same year as the false union of Brest-Litovsk was concluded between Rome and some Russian
bishops. His father was a Lithuanian nobleman of modest means, but Athanasius acquired
breath and depth of learning that were exceptional at that time.
Besides modern and ancient languages and the writings of the Holy Fathers,
he was familiar with the works of Western philosophers and theologians.
In the year 1627, after spending several years as a private tutor, he became a monk
at the monastery of Kuthin near Orshah in Little Russia.
This monastery was independent of the Polish occupying forces, and by tradition deeply
committed to the preservation of Orthodoxy so that it was able to offer great encouragement
to the Orthodox people in the face of Roman Catholic propaganda.
Athanasius went on to follow his monastic path in other renowned monasteries, and was ordained
priest. The Metropolitan of Kiev, Peter Mogila, gave him the task of restoring the monastery of
Kupiatiks. In obedience to a divine revelation, Athanasius set out for Moscow, a long and dangerous
journey through territory under Polish occupation, in order to ask for financial assistance for the
restoration and to acquaint the Tsar with the fate intended for the Orthodox Church in the lands
to the southwest of Russia. He was successful in his quest, and with the help of the mother of God,
the restoration works were begun. Two years later, Athanasius was appointed abbot of the
monastery of St. Simeon the Stylite in Brecht-Litovsk. From then on, he went to be a resolute
and tireless fighter against Roman proselytism clothed in Orthodox rites and customs known as the
Unia. For the next eight years, by prayer, preaching and through his writings, the saint devoted
all his strength to refuting the false union, and to bringing back to the holy sheepfold of Christ,
those who had strayed. The population of the occupied territories was brutally treated by the
Polish soldiers and colonists, nor did the Jesuit missionaries for their part abstain from any measure
that might serve to lead the peoples of Little Russia to accept their faith. In this situation,
Saint Athanasius decided to petition the king of Poland, Vladislav IV, that the Orthodox be treated
with more humanity. The king was moved by his request and issued a decree for bidding the abuses
that had occurred, but his officials ignored it. The condition of the Orthodox in Warsaw was
particularly bad. It was not unknown for the Poles and Uniaz to set fire to Orthodox churches
on feast days when they were full of the faithful, just as had happened in the time of the great
persecutions. Athanasius kept up the fight, aided, and comforted by none but the mother of God,
and in the year 1643 following a new revelation, he again appealed for redress on behalf
of the Orthodox to the Polish Council of State. He received a favorable hearing, and the Orthodox
were granted some legal protection. But certain Orthodox men of rank, fearing for their privileges,
claimed that the saint was mad and succeeded in having him deprived of his abyssey,
deposed from the priesthood and sent to Kiev to answer before a church court.
The humble Athanasius was completely exonerated and restored to his position,
but he did not have peace for long. Since persecution of the Orthodox soon began again.
He drew up a petition intended for the king of Poland, but was arrested and thrown into prison
before he was able to complete it. He was released after three years' detention,
but in the year 1648 a persecution broke out that was more terrible than ever before.
So bloody was it that the people of little Russia rose up and demanded the departure of the Polish
Lithuanian army and the restoration of Russian territory to the Tsar. The Polish authorities
immediately arrested the rebel leaders and prominent Orthodox dignitaries.
Saint Athanasius was imprisoned, an endured physical and mental torment of all kinds at the hands
of his jailers and of the Roman Catholic authorities, but he never ceased to cry, a nathema to the union.
After being tortured with red-hot calls, he was flayed and burnt alive.
As he was still not dead, his executioners shot him. They threw his decapitated corpse into a pit
where it was found some time later, incorrupt. In the years that followed, the relics of the Holy
martyr worked many miracles. Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ, our
God, have mercy on us and save us.